jahrhunderts ist virtuell und jeder darf
mit zwitschern und mit spucken
er bricht über uns herein wie eine
naturkatastrophe gewaltätig
unberechenbar wie aus dem nichts kommt
ein shitstorm braut sich irgendwo in der
welt zusammen manchmal ganz spontan
angetrieben von der empörung und der
anonymität des internets
was diese entwicklung aus unserem guten
alten skandal macht hat ein
wissenschaftler beschrieben der seit
jahren die dynamik des internets
erforscht jeder kann mitmachen jeder
besitzt die instrumente der
skandalisierung in form eines
smartphones in form einer digitalkamera
die bahn benutzen kann um etwas was sein
aufregt empört aufzunehmen zu
dokumentieren und womöglich einer welt
gemeinde vor augen zu führen
so zum beispiel nach der talkshow markus
lanz in der sich der moderator
offensichtlich als harter knochen
profilieren seinen gast sahra
wagenknecht so richtig in die mangel
nehmen wollte
das ist überhaupt nicht die frage
wir sind drin und auch mein auflösen
sollte es denke ich jetzt aktuell nicht
das problem
die frage die frage stellen das
interview war gewiss keine sternstunde
des journalismus doch was es auslöst war
ein shitstorm gewaltigen ausmaßes
angetrieben von emotionen die aus
friedlichen menschen wutbürger machten
gewalttätig und schwer berechenbar wie
ein wirbelsturm der zeitweise drohte
markus lanz vom bildschirm zu fliegen
raus mit lan land duca abstempeln als
listig der schweizer daniel graf hat für
fälle wie diesen ein shitstorm barometer
entwickelt das parallel zur
wettervorhersage den sturm der erregung
in buchform ist herr lanz und pfiffen
ich sage mal es ist nur ein schritt
unter demokraten orkan hat für mich zum
beispiel bedeutet das dann ludwig auf
der straße standen werk mit plakat und
seite der lanz muss weg ich denke
entschied storm ist es korrektur
instrument aus dem gott das tatsache
dynamik gekümmert er wirkung entfaltet
gartmann glüht enttäuscht sind
der sturm als ausdruck von
schwarmintelligenz beim korrektur
instrument bei dem sich unter einer flut
von empörung ein wahrer kern verbirgt
denn bestimmt ein schützen aus einem
kern schwarmintelligenz umgeben von
einer flut schwarm dummheit ein
leithammel gibt den ton an und alle
blüten unter herdentrieb in der neuen
medienwelt
es ist die form der modernen
wertedebatte wissen nicht mehr was
positiv gelten soll aber wir können uns
doch darauf einigen was uns aufregt
wovon wir uns abgrenzen
wem oder was wir mit einem wut schreibt
kommentieren das heißt dies dauer
skandalisierung ist in verdeckter form
eine wertedebatte was soll gelten was
darf auf keinen fall sein welche norm
überall enorm verletzung gilt es zu
ernten
ein shitstorm 2010 entfacht von diesem
greenpeace video gegen kitkat weil
nestlé palmöl verwendet dafür dass die
regenwälder der orang utans abgeholzt
worden
der konzern ernte der beschimpfung aber
auch fundierte kritik
konzerne wie nestlé fürchten den image
verlust denn solches schiffsfonds
entfachen können unsicheren umgang mit
diesem phänomen setzt nestlé heute auf
überwachung und nennt es monitoring gibt
damit reagiere ich denke aber dass ich
die kulisse will sie zum hand dynamik wo
er extrem schwierig erfassbar ist von
dem her war es dann gemerkt hat ist er
meistens sport daniel graf hat selbst
schon schützt uns entfacht und eine
anleitung dazu ins internet gestellt
denn solche empörung stürme sind für ihn
eine moderne form der basisdemokratie
das problem ist nur dass solch ein sturm
und berechenbar ist etwa so als würden
in einer diskussionsrunde
hunderttausende gleichzeitig legen
uneinig darüber welcher ton angemessen
und wie das thema einzugrenzen ist
wir müssen uns mit der frage
beschäftigen wie wir im digitalen
zeitalter leben wie wir die instrumente
die oft großartigen die oft wunderbaren
kommunikationsinstrumente auf eine weise
benutzen die produktives die uns
voranbringt die unseren debatten reife
und klärung liefert die weltweite
internet gemeinde ist also noch in einer
lernphase ziel weniger herdentrieb mehr
schwarmintelligenz wenn die intelligenz
des schwarms auf die elementare kraft
empörend trifft hat das
internetzeitalter eine neue form der
volksinitiative gefunden